Die Schweiz - ein Land,
in dem man gerne lebt.
Ein Land, in dem
eigentlich alles funktioniert.
Prochain arrêt Lausanne. Bonjour.
Viele Menschen
tragen im Hintergrund dazu bei.
Cla Duri Blanke
fällt Bäume im Engadin.
Rita Streuli kontrolliert Billette
bei den Zürcher Verkehrsbetrieben.
Hansjörg Schwizer
markiert Signalisationen
auf Appenzells Strassen.
Und Sabina Fehr
führt einen Zoo im Tessin.
Wie leben diese Menschen?
Wofür setzen sie sich ein?
Und was beschäftigt sie?
Vier Menschen und ihr Alltag -
ein Tag im Leben der Schweiz.
Kurz vor 3.30 Uhr
in Urdorf bei Zürich.
Die 28-jährige Rita wohnt allein.
Ich bin eigentlich
überhaupt kein Morgenmuffel.
Ich kann eigentlich
am Morgen schon drauflos schwatzen.
Die Leute um mich herum
mögen das gar nicht.
Aber das war schon immer so.
Ich kann eigentlich immer schwatzen.
Kurz später in Appenzell.
Der 47-jährige Hansjörg
steht ebenfalls gerne früh auf.
Auch wenn ich frei habe,
ich muss raus.
Ich stehe dann trotzdem auf.
Dann in Ruhe einen Kaffee trinken,
schauen, wie es tagt,
das ist schön.
Dann hast du noch etwas vom Tag.
Rita ist bereits
auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Die quirlige Busfahrerin
hat immer das gleiche Ritual.
* Rockige Musik aus dem Autoradio:
"Hold Me Back" von AC/DC *
Es gibt mir einfach
immer so ein Gefühl,
richtig glücklich zu sein,
wenn ich das höre, wenn er sagt:
"Can't hold me back" -
nichts hält mich zurück.
# Can't hold me back.
Im Unterengadin.
Der 30-jährige Cla Duri
geht den Tag langsam an.
Seine Frau und die drei Kinder
schlafen noch.
Das war schon das Frühstück.
Ein Joghurt braucht es fast,
sonst muss man
die Rösti schon um 9 Uhr machen.
Cla Duri ist in Ftan aufgewachsen.
Ftan gefällt mir sehr gut.
Es könnte schon sein,
dass ich vielleicht mal weggehe,
aber eigentlich lebe ich gut hier.
Zürich. Rita muss ihren Bus fassen.
Ich bin eigentlich gelernte Köchin
und durch einen grossen Zufall
Chauffeurin geworden.
Ich ging mal in Zürich aus,
am Bellevue,
und sah ein Plakat der VBZ,
auf dem stand, dass sie gerne
eine grössere Frauenquote hätten.
Ja, und darauf
habe ich mich eigentlich beworben.
Ist das mein Bus?
Ja, 409, das ist mein Bus.
Ich muss hier die Kurstafel stecken,
damit man hier
den richtigen Kurs drin hat.
Der Frauenanteil bei den
Verkehrsbetrieben Zürich, kurz VBZ,
liegt bei 18,8 %.
Gesamthaft
sind 1'300 Leute im Einsatz.
In Appenzell.
Hansjörg nimmt sich am Morgen
immer Zeit für seine Hasenzucht.
Er ist einer von rund 10'000
Kaninchenzüchter in der Schweiz.
Ja, bist ein braver Kerl.
Belgische Riesen.
Also das sind jetzt die Jungen,
die werden noch viel grösser.
Die grösste Rasse,
die man in der Schweiz
für Ausstellungen anerkannt hat.
Dann gibt es aber auch solche,
die nicht ganz perfekt sind,
die optisch vielleicht einfach
keinen schönen Rücken haben
oder zu lange oder zu kurze Ohren
oder bei denen das Fell nicht
genug schön ist zum Ausstellen.
Aus denen machen wir dann schon
ab und zu einen Braten.
Nicht wahr?
Ja, jetzt habt ihr wieder.
Es ist 7 Uhr. Im Zoo von Magliaso
ist es noch ruhig.
Buongiorno.
Sabina ist hier aufgewachsen.
Ihre Eltern zogen vor 44 Jahren
von Basel ins Tessin
und gründeten diesen Zoo.
Vor drei Jahren hat nun
Sabina die Leitung übernommen.
Und vor kurzer Zeit ist sie
mit 44 selbst noch Mutter geworden.
Mami,
darf ich dir das Babyphone geben?
Ich wusste nicht, wo du bist.
Ihre Mutter hat den Zoo
die letzten 20 Jahre alleine geführt.
Hallo, Jimmy, guten Morgen.
Ihr Freund Federico kümmert sich
um alles Technische hier.
Magari
andiamo un' attimo dentro a vedere.
Sabina hat zehn Jahre lang
andere Jobs gemacht,
bevor sie zurückgekommen ist.
Es ist ein anderer Lebensrhythmus.
Mit den Tieren
ist es wie mit den Kindern:
Sie geben den Rhythmus vor -
und wir hetzen auch nicht.
Wenn man Tiere hetzt,
ist das sehr schlecht,
die vertragen Stress gar nicht,
also sie reagieren darauf.
Aber für Sabina
und ihre fünf Angestellten
gibt es sehr viel zu tun.
Sono impazienti. Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Hoi.
Hier gab es gestern ein Junges.
Die Kapuzineraffen
krallen sich fest,
also die Mutter
muss nichts mehr tun.
Solange es sich so gut festhält,
ist alles gut.
Im Wald unterhalb von Scuol.
Cla Duri
ist mit zwei Lehrlingen unterwegs.
Sie müssen Bäume fällen, weil diese
den Stromleitungen im Weg sind.
(Rätoromanisch)
Wenn man gerne in der Natur ist
und körperliche Arbeit leistet
und die eine oder andere Arbeit
mit Maschinen macht,
dann nimmt man
auch die Gefahren in Kauf.
Achtung!
In den letzten zehn Jahren
hat es drei grössere Unfälle gegeben.
Bei einem ist ein Lehrling gestorben.
Wegen der Gefahren ...
Seit man Familie hat,
schaut man vielleicht schon mehr
auf die eine oder andere Sache,
aber ganz verhindern, dass etwas
passiert, kann man nie, das ist so.
Ein schönes Gefühl.
Dieser hier - na ja.
Aber wenn ein richtig grosser Baum
zu Boden fällt,
dann ist das schon etwas Schönes.
Zurück im Tessin.
Sabinas Tochter Lisa ist aufgewacht.
Ihre Mutter Edith
hat eine neue Aufgabe.
Hast du Tränchen in den Augen?
Die Stabsübergabe zwischen den beiden
Frauen war nicht ganz einfach.
Morgen, Schätzchen.
Wir haben sehr unterschiedliche
Arbeits- und Sichtweisen,
deshalb war das am Anfang
sehr, sehr schwierig.
Irgendwann hat sich das dann
nach drei Jahren gut eingespielt.
Dadurch, dass ich weiss,
dass ich nicht Zeit für alles habe,
habe ich geschaut, dass die Leute
so selbstständig wie möglich sind,
die Angestellten, und habe sie
auch dementsprechend eingeführt.
Meine Mutter hingegen musste immer
alles unter Kontrolle haben,
den Leuten sagen, was sie zu tun
haben, und sie war auch immer dabei.
Sein lassen, Wasser sein lassen!
Du bist eine Ulknudel du.
Ist gut?
Hallo.
Lisa wächst gleich wie Sabina
im Zoo auf, und Sabina ist froh,
dass sie und ihre Mutter eine
gute Arbeitsteilung gefunden haben.
Wenn ihr nicht am Schatten seid,
sollte es reichen,
wenn sie unten nichts trägt.
So, rücken wir aus, wagen wir's!
Kurz nach 8 Uhr in Appenzell.
Hansjörg
arbeitet im Strassenunterhalt.
Heute müssen er
und seine beiden Kumpels
die Mittelstreifen
auf der Kantonsstrasse
von Appenzell Richtung Schlatt-Haslen
neu malen.
Hansjörg ist der Einzige im Kanton,
der die Maschine bedienen kann.
Auf der Strasse, wenn du am Arbeiten
bist, bist du allen im Weg.
Nicht allen, es hat auch solche,
die Bescheid wissen.
Aber viele haben heute
schon eine Hektik,
die meines Erachtens ungesund ist.
Ah, gefährlich.
Ja, gefährlich ist das schon.
Ja, du musst bei der Sache sein.
Wir mussten auch schon wegrennen,
weil einer einfach auf uns losfuhr.
Ich weiss halt auch nicht,
ob sie dich nicht sehen
oder nicht sehen wollen.
Manchmal
ist es dann schon gefährlich.
Nein, das reicht.
Wir haben auch noch genügend Primer.
Aber die Gefahr ist nicht das,
was er am schlimmsten findet.
Es nervt mich lange nichts, aber was
mir jetzt gerade in den Sinn kommt,
ist der Abfall,
den sie wegwerfen heute.
Überall, auch wenn du wandern gehst
oder bei der Arbeit,
müssen wir immer wieder
Müll einsammeln.
Es würde nicht viel brauchen,
dann würde es ganz anders aussehen.
Stosszeit in Zürich.
Jeden Tag benutzen
rund 1 Mio. Menschen die VBZ.
Ja, du hast genügend Platz.
Rita ist seit 3 Std. unterwegs.
Gut, ha.
Kleine Verkehrshindernisse wie diese
führen logischerweise
zu Verspätungen.
Das schätzen die Fahrgäste gar nicht.
Meistens kommen sie, um es zu sagen,
manchmal stehen sie aber
auch an der Haltestelle
und zeigen demonstrativ auf die Uhr,
um dir zu zeigen,
dass du zu spät unterwegs bist,
was ich leider nicht ändern kann.
Kein Chauffeur
fährt absichtlich zu spät herum.
Wir geben alle unser Bestes.
Aber es gibt auch
immer wieder freundliche Begegnungen.
(Frau) Wichtig ist,
dass man immer Turnschuhe trägt.
Ja, ich ...
Tragen Sie gute Schuhe?
Mit Absätzen ist das
ein No-Go in den Kurven und so.
Keine High Heels?
- (Frauen) Nein, nein.
Sonst schon? Aber im Bus nicht.
- Nein, nein, nur noch gesund.
Nur noch Gesundheitsschuhe?
- Sie merken das dann auch noch.
Sie haben das gut gemacht um
diese Kurven rum, sanft waren Sie.
Es gibt manchmal Rassige,
das bin ich auch.
Sind Sie auch eher rassig?
Ich merk's ja.
Beim Autofahren.
- Ah, beim Autofahren.
(Lachend)
Ich dachte, sonst so als Person.
Gute Fahrt.
- Danke vielmals.
Mir ist wichtig,
dass man das Gegenüber wertschätzt.
Egal, ob das ein Buschauffeur ist,
ob das jemand ist,
der bei Schutz und Rettung arbeitet,
der Container leert, jeder
hat seinen Teil hier in der Schweiz
und es ist wichtig, dass man
jeden genau gleich behandelt,
so wie man selbst
auch behandelt werden möchte.
Zurück in den Bergen.
Pause für die Förster.
Es ist vielleicht
schon ein bisschen so,
dass die Holzfäller nicht die sind,
die am meisten reden.
Sie arbeiten lieber.
In der Schweiz werden jährlich
mehr als 6 Mio. Bäume gefällt.
Alles muss
wieder aufgeforstet werden.
Die Holzpreise sind momentan tief.
Das Holz hier geht z.T.
in die Sägerei von Tarasp.
Der grösste Teil wird jedoch nach
Italien oder Österreich verkauft.
Es ist 11 Uhr.
Eine von Sabinas Lieblingsaufgaben
ist die Fellpflege von Jimmy.
Der Gibbonaffe
ist zehn Jahre älter als sie
und hat sie schon
durch ihr ganzes Leben begleitet.
Er ist liebesbedürftig,
und das zeigt er dann auch.
Das beruhigt mich auch,
das ist eine Art Erholungsmoment.
Begonnen haben Sabinas Eltern
mit einem kranken Löwen.
Mittlerweile
leben rund 220 Tiere hier.
Schon fertig?
Wir sind aber noch nicht fertig.
Hier müssen wir noch fertig putzen,
machen wir nachher weiter?
Der kleine Privatzoo
hat als Pflegestation begonnen.
In der Zwischenzeit macht er
auch bei Zuchtprogrammen mit.
Nur etwa vier der rund 30 Zoos
in der Schweiz sind privat.
Sie werden von Tierschützern
besonders stark bekämpft,
obwohl sie die gleichen Regeln
einhalten müssen wie die grossen.
Hallo, Jimmy.
Komm, gib mir kurz dein Bein!
Jawohl.
Ist gut?
Das Tierschutzgesetz
verbessert sich ja konstant.
Da sind wir eigentlich
schon jahrelang dran ...
Jimmy, gib mir bitte einen Arm!
... die Anlagen zu vergrössern,
also die Tierarten zu reduzieren
und die Anlagen zu vergrössern.
Und einfach immer wieder
Weiterbildungen machen.
Und wenn wieder
eine neue Vorschrift kommt,
hat man ja eine gewisse Zeit,
um sich anzupassen.
Dass man einfach immer schaut,
dass die neuen Strukturen
dem entsprechen.
Gibst du mir noch deinen Arm,
damit ich ihn waschen kann?
Nein, den anderen.
Der ist schon sauber.
Schau, du bist frisé -
d.h., dass du gewaschen bist.
Komm, gib mir den anderen bitte!
Den hier.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Mittag in der Schweiz.
Hansjörg
fährt zum Essen immer nach Hause.
Nur zwei der vier Kinder
essen noch daheim.
Dir geht es auch gut?
Ja, eine kalte Nase hast du.
- Ja, es zieht auf dem Töff.
Komm, wir setzen uns!
Aber es hat
immer noch andere Kinder hier.
Manuela, meine Frau,
ist Tagesmutter.
Und jetzt ist er ja hier bei uns,
Leon, und isst bei uns zu Mittag,
nicht wahr?
Und dann holt dich Mama
am Abend wieder.
Benjamin, ihr Jüngster, hat
eine schwere Stoffwechselkrankheit,
die das Gehirn angreifen würde,
wenn er nicht
eine strenge Diät einhalten würde.
Entdeckt wurde sie
kurz nach der Geburt.
Nur eines von 90'000 Kindern
in der Schweiz ist betroffen.
Der Kinderarzt sagte,
als wir nach der Geburt
vom Spital nach Hause gingen,
wir hätten da einen wackeren,
gesunden, kräftigen Jungen.
Und dann kam dieser Anruf -
und dann dieser Weg nach Zürich,
diese Autofahrt war unendlich lang.
Uns gingen
1'000 Gedanken durch den Kopf.
Ja, für uns brach eine Welt zusammen
in dem Moment.
Mittlerweile
haben sich alle daran gewöhnt,
doch es hatte schon
Auswirkungen auf die Familie,
v.a. für Manuela.
Ich habe Pharmaassistentin gelernt,
das ist mein Beruf.
Und wegen Benjamins Krankheit
hat es uns den ganzen Plan
ein bisschen
über den Haufen geworfen,
weil es eben nicht einfach ist,
Benjamin jemandem zu geben,
also dass eine Freundin
oder die Grossmutter für ihn kocht.
Wir haben dann entschieden,
dass ich nicht mehr arbeiten werde,
auch Teilzeit nicht.
Dass ich bei den Kindern bleibe
und auf sie schaue.
Und irgendwie
habe ich dann irgendwann
ein Inserat in der Zeitung gelesen,
dass sie eine Tagesmutter suchen,
und habe mich darauf gemeldet.
Dann hatte ich je länger je mehr
Anfragen und immer wieder.
Ja,
so kommen wir zu unseren Kindern.
Cla Duri und seine Kollegen
essen im Wald.
Heute hatten wir sehr viel Fantasie.
(Rätoromanisch)
Gewisse Sachen koche ich.
Einfaches kann ich schon machen.
Aber nicht, dass ich jetzt einen
Kochkurs oder so besucht hätte.
Manchmal
muss man einfach ausprobieren,
und wenn es gut ist, dann macht man
das nächste Mal das Gleiche,
und sonst macht man etwas anderes.
Spaghetti oder auch andere Sachen
kann ich schon machen.
Ma si.
* Lachen *
Zurück im Zoo.
Sabinas Freund Federico
ist eigentlich Koch.
Kurz nachdem sich die beiden
vor neun Jahren kennengelernt hatten,
entschied Sabina,
den Zoo zu übernehmen.
Federico hat mitgezogen -
und es macht ihm Spass.
Grossmutter Edith hat gekocht.
Die junge Familie
lebt vorläufig in ihrem Haus.
Sie möchten gerne aufstocken, aber
die Baubewilligung verzögert sich.
Das, was ich im Moment
gerne verändern würde,
ist jetzt
wirklich die Wohnsituation.
So wie wir nun provisorisch
in diesem Haus eingezogen sind ...
Wir haben einen Teil unserer Sachen
mitgenommen,
aber ein grosser Teil
war bereits im Haus.
Ja, es ist einfach ...
Wir sind noch nicht ganz zu Hause.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit. - Buon appetito.
Als Edith
ihr Haus den Jungen übergab,
musste sie erst mal
für eine Weile weg.
Sie hatte Mühe, loszulassen.
Aber nun hat sie sich daran gewöhnt.
Wir Alten ... ähm ... Älteren
wollen es nicht so wahrhaben,
aber es ist einfach so.
Man kann nicht mehr,
ob man will oder nicht.
Gell? Es ist einfach so.
Und ... äh ... ja.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Zurück in Zürich. Rita hat nur
schnell ein Sandwich verdrückt,
jetzt macht sie Billettkontrolle.
Meist arbeiten sie
in gemischten Teams.
Ich mache wieder von der Mitte an,
okay?
So, Billettkontrolle, hallo.
* Handy *
Ja, wunderbar, danke vielmals,
einen schönen Tag.
Wenn du den Fahrgästen ein Lächeln
entgegenbringst und Grüezi sagst,
ist das schon die halbe Miete.
Dementsprechend begegnen dir die
Leute auch schon viel freundlicher
und sind eher bereit,
dir dann die Wahrheit zu sagen,
wenn es drum geht,
dass jemand kein Billett hat.
Dann fällt es einem
ein bisschen leichter.
Grüezi, Billettkontrolle.
bitte alle Billette vorweisen!
Jahresabo abgelaufen.
- Okay.
Genau,
wir steigen noch schnell mit aus.
Dann erklären wir Ihnen das.
- Ah, okay.
Der wäre jetzt
noch 1 Std. als Ticket gültig.
Vielen Dank.
- Einen schönen Tag. Adieu.
Man muss sich manchmal selbst
total an der Nase nehmen,
dass man nicht sagt:
"Der dort hinten hat sicher keines."
Es ist dann meistens so,
dass dann ein Mann,
der im Anzug ist und im Schlips,
wirklich gar nichts hat,
und der andere ein Jahresabo hat.
Die Strategie mit der Freundlichkeit
funktioniert meistens,
aber nicht immer.
Rita wurde auch schon
tätlich angegriffen.
Es war an einem Wochenende,
an einem Sonntagmorgen,
der Fahrgast war alkoholisiert.
Die Situation explodierte dann
eigentlich aus dem Nichts.
Weil er dann keinen Ausweg sah,
denke ich, schlug er mich.
Danke, einen schönen Tag.
Ich musste dann ins Spital.
Es war zum Glück nichts,
hatte keinen bleibenden Schaden.
Vielleicht seelisch ein bisschen,
dass du ein mulmiges Gefühl hast,
wenn du wieder jemanden hast,
der alkoholisiert ist
und dann ausrastet,
aber sonst habe ich es
eigentlich gut verarbeitet.
Im Appenzellerland.
Wir fahren jetzt hier weiter
mit dieser Mittellinie
bis zur Kantonsgrenze.
Dann hören wir auf.
Dann können die anderen schauen,
was sie dort machen.
Wenn sie
unsere schönen Striche sehen hier.
Für Hansjörg ist das hier sowieso
der schönste Flecken auf Erden.
Bei uns
ist alles ein bisschen speziell.
Schön ist, wenn du in
einem solchen Gebiet malen kannst,
das ist sicher etwas,
das einem noch mehr Freude macht.
Die Kulisse, die wir hier haben.
Das ist sicher schöner,
als wenn du in einer Stadt bist.
Innerhalb von Minuten
schlägt das Wetter um.
So kann es gehen,
das erleben wir oft im Sommer.
Jetzt regnet es, jetzt regnet es,
jetzt ist fertig mit Malen.
Nun müssen wir eine Weile warten,
bis es wieder trocken ist,
und dann packen wir alles zusammen.
Nachher zurück zum Stützpunkt.
Ein richtiges Gewitter.
Geduld haben die Herren
dann doch nicht so viel.
Gut!
Rund 1'000 kg Farbe werden jedes Jahr
allein auf den 65 km Strasse
im Kanton Appenzell vermalt.
Fast 18'000 km Kantonsstrasse
gibt es in der ganzen Schweiz.
Wir gehen.
Geh rein, du!
(Mann) Seid ihr nass geworden?
(Mann) Nein, es ist trocken, oder?
- Ja.
Buongiorno.
Rund 35'000 Menschen besuchen
den Zoo von Magliaso jedes Jahr.
Löhne und Futterkosten
fressen die Einnahmen aber auf.
Es geht auf, aber knapp.
Wir haben Fixkosten
von 250'000 Fr. für das ganze Jahr.
Mind. das müssen wir während
der Saison einnehmen und schauen,
dass wir auch noch
ein bisschen Reserven machen.
Questo é per le scimmie,
per gli animali.
Sì, per tutti eccetto le tartarughe,
il leone e i leopardi.
Im Gegensatz zu den grossen Zoos
ist es für Sabina schwierig,
an grosszügige Spendengelder
heranzukommen.
Wenn ich an den Basler Zolli
oder an den Zürcher Zoo denke,
bei diesen Institutionen muss man
dabei sein, sonst ist man nicht in.
Im Tessin ist das anders.
Als gelernte PR-Frau versucht Sabina,
mit Veranstaltungen
wie Kindergeburtstagen und Hochzeiten
zusätzlich Geld zu verdienen.
Das sind auch gute Gelegenheiten,
die Besucher
für die Tiere zu sensibilisieren.
(Italienisch)
(Kinder) Io!
- (Kind) La festeggiata.
(Lachend) Scremare i coraggiosi?
Mehlwürmer mögen die Kapuzineraffen
besonders gerne.
* Die Kinder
sprechen durcheinander. *
* Kreischen *
Etwa 60 Kindergeburtstage
organisiert Sabina pro Jahr.
Cla Duri ist fertig für heute.
Er ist auf dem Weg
zum Bauernhof seiner Eltern.
Ich habe im Sinn,
einmal den Bauernhof meiner Eltern
zu übernehmen.
Zuerst habe ich Bauer gelernt, und
weil mein Vater noch zu jung war,
um mir den Betrieb zu übergeben,
habe ich Forstwart gelernt,
weil das mein zweiter Favorit war.
Eigentlich bin ich zufrieden
mit meinem Beruf.
Wenn ich nicht
den Bauernhof in Sicht hätte,
würde ich wahrscheinlich
auch nichts daran ändern.
Seine Kinder verbringen ihre Zeit
meist auf dem Bauernhof.
Jetzt warten wir noch kurz, bis die
Mutter die Eier eingesammelt hat.
Die sind ja überall verstreut.
Neben Schafen und Kühen hat es hier
Hühner, Schweine, Kaninchen
und zwei Ziegen.
Ein Paradies für die Kinder.
Die Ziegen und die Kaninchen
sind v.a. für die Kinder.
Die haben Freude daran.
Es gibt halt sofort einen Haufen
Arbeit, aber es ist schon schön.
Alle helfen mit.
Quantas van sü?
Cla Duri ist ein friedlicher Mensch.
Ihm geht es am besten,
wenn es allen wohl ist um ihn herum.
Man will es allen recht machen,
der Familie, dem Forstamt ...
Man will es dem Vater und der Mutter
auf dem Bauernhof recht machen -
und es geht gar nicht,
es allen recht zu machen.
Das ist etwas, was ich gemerkt habe.
Man hat manchmal
zu viele Eisen im Feuer.
Man kann gar nicht alles machen,
und ich mag keine halben Sachen.
Auf der Landstrasse
Richtung Weinfelden.
Rita fährt einmal in der Woche zu
ihrer Mutter in den Kanton Thurgau.
Wo fühlt sie sich mehr zu Hause?
Zürich ist halt ... Ich wohne dort.
Beide Orte
sind ein bisschen meine Heimat.
Dort arbeite ich,
dort ist mein Mittelpunkt,
aber wenn ich ins Thurgau rauskomme
zu meiner Mutter,
dann fühle ich mich
auch wieder ein bisschen so ...
Ein Rückzugsort, um wieder
ein bisschen Energie zu tanken.
Das ist auch meine Heimat
oder ein Teil meiner Heimat.
Hier hat Rita
zwischen 14 und 20 gewohnt.
Jetzt lebt ihre Mutter
mit Hund Alfie alleine hier.
Hoi.
* Bellen *
Ihre ältere Schwester Anita
ist leicht geistig behindert
und lebt in einem Heim.
Aber die drei
haben eine sehr enge Beziehung
und nutzen jede Gelegenheit,
um Zeit gemeinsam zu verbringen.
Ihre Familiengeschichte
hat sie zusammengeschweisst.
Der Vater
hatte beide Töchter missbraucht.
Rita war sechs, ihre Schwester 14,
als die Mutter sich von ihm trennte
und Anzeige erstattete.
Mit den Jahren dann irgendwann
kam immer wieder
ein bisschen etwas hervor.
Auch mir selbst
kamen Sachen wieder in den Sinn.
Und dann gab es halt manchmal
Probleme in der Schule
mit gewissen Sachen.
Und dann musste ich
auch zum Psychologen,
und dort kamen Sachen ans Licht.
Und dann ... Es war, wie wenn du es
immer wieder erzählen musst,
dann hängt es dir irgendwann
einfach zum Hals raus.
Es half mir mehr, wenn ich
mit dir darüber reden konnte.
Und du, Anita,
bist halt wieder ein anderer Mensch.
Für dich stimmt es so, wenn du ...
Ich schon mit dir,
aber ich weiss nicht ...
Du kannst dich einfach ein bisschen
besser öffnen bei der Psychologin.
Sie macht es auch gut.
Für die Mutter war es ein Schock, sie
quälte sich jahrelang mit Vorwürfen.
Ich habe oft gedacht:
"Hätte ich mich so
oder nicht so verhalten,
wäre es vielleicht anders gewesen."
Man denkt schon darüber nach,
aber es bringt einem ja nichts.
Ändern kannst du es eh nicht mehr.
- Nein.
Aber eben, du bist nicht ...
Du kannst nichts dafür,
dass das passiert ist.
Das ist nicht unsere Schuld.
Ich kann nichts dafür,
dass mir das passiert ist.
Es ist passiert,
aber ich lebe mein Leben weiter.
Auch mit dem Gedanken,
dass ich weiss,
dass das in der Kindheit passiert
ist und dass ich das Gefühl habe,
dass ich manchmal
einen etwas schwierigen Start hatte,
aber trotzdem mache ich das,
was ich mache.
Ich mache es gerne.
Ich mache meine Arbeit gerne, ich
liebe das Leben, ich bin glücklich.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Zurück in Magliaso.
Na, George.
Der Pfau versucht,
die Hühner zu bezirzen,
aber es funktioniert
irgendwie nicht.
Ecco.
* Sie lacht. *
Es ist Fütterungszeit.
Ma é un maiale?
- E un cervo.
Löwen fressen 5-6 kg am Tag
und haben einmal pro Woche Pause,
um den Darm zu entleeren.
Es ist eigentlich
ein Nachahmen der Natur.
In der Natur essen sie
natürlich sehr viel auf einmal
und nachher
eine Woche lang gar nichts
oder bis sie
die nächste Beute haben.
Cleo muss viel essen,
sie erwartet Nachwuchs.
Die zweieinhalbjährige Löwin
kommt vom Plättli Zoo in Frauenfeld.
Max stammt aus dem letzten Wurf hier
vor 14 Jahren.
Es ist das erste Mal
seit seiner Geburt,
dass es im Zoo
wieder Löwenbabys geben wird.
In Ftan arbeiten Vater und Sohn
zusammen - so gut es geht.
Eigentlich haben mein Vater und ich
eine gute Beziehung.
Die Zusammenarbeit funktioniert gut.
Es sind mehr die Ansichten,
die sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Wenn einer A will,
will der andere B,
und das nächste Mal
ist es umgekehrt.
Meistens muss ich nachgeben,
weil es ja nicht mein Bauernhof ist.
Z.B. versteht Cla Duri
überhaupt nicht,
warum sein Vater
Landkarten im Stall aufhängt.
Hier seht ihr ein Schwalbennest.
Diese Schwalben
sind schon zurückgekehrt,
und als die Schafe gefragt haben,
woher diese Vögel kommen,
habe ich es ihnen
auf der Landkarte zeigen können.
Arme Schafe, was die sich
jeden Tag anhören müssen.
Nein, ich würde solche Sachen
nicht im Stall aufhängen.
Tuot bel.
- Nicht wahr? Das ist schön.
Wenn Mias kommt,
kann ich ihm manchmal etwas
erklären, oder Nuri und auch Lio.
260 km entfernt
in Sulgen im Kanton Thurgau.
Rita liebt es, gemeinsam
mit ihrer Schwester Anita zu kochen,
wenn sie bei der Mutter sind.
Die müssen wir
in Streifen schneiden.
Und ich schneide hier mal vor.
Die muss ich
nachher nochmals abwaschen.
Ich liebe ganz besonders an Anita,
dass sie so eine liebe,
sanfte Seele hat
und niemandem etwas tun kann.
Sie möchte es allen
recht machen können.
Und ich denke mir immer,
dass ich mir eine grosse Scheibe
von ihr abschneiden könnte.
* Rita lacht. *
Huch, potztausend!
Kriegst du das auf?
Ich krieg das nicht auf.
Oh, super. Du bist ja stark!
Wir kochen eigentlich immer zusammen
und sagen der Mutter,
sie soll hinten bleiben
und sich ein bisschen entspannen.
Aber sie kommt trotzdem
immer wieder nach vorn
und fragt uns,
ob sie etwas helfen kann.
Mir ist wichtig,
dass ich mit meiner Mutter
noch ein bisschen reisen kann,
weil sie kaum die Chance hatte,
andere Länder zu bereisen.
Auch mal etwas weiter als
nur bis zu den Kanarischen Inseln.
Das wäre mir wichtig,
dass ich das noch machen könnte,
solange ich
meine Mutter noch um mich habe.
40 km entfernt.
Auch in Appenzell gibt es Abendessen.
Guten Appetit.
- (Alle) Guten Appetit.
Einen leckeren Zopf hast du gemacht.
Dass Hansjörg
seinem Familienleben so Sorge trägt,
hat einen speziellen Grund.
Ich war verheiratet,
und nach einem halben Jahr
starb meine erste Frau
bei einem Verkehrsunfall.
Wir waren mit den Velos unterwegs.
Und dann, weil meine Mutter
die Gotte seiner ersten Frau war,
hat sie ihn ein paar Monate später
mal zum Nachtessen eingeladen.
Und ich ging gerne wandern,
wie er auch.
Und dann hat er gesagt,
er hätte gar keine Lust mehr,
allein wandern zu gehen.
Dann sagte ich:
"Ich komme schon mal mit."
Und dann sind wir einmal
nach der Arbeit am Abend
zum Seealpsee gelaufen.
Es war Vollmond,
ein wunderschöner Abend.
Das folgende Wochenende gingen wir
wieder wandern - und irgendwie so.
Zum Spitzi hinauf.
- Genau.
Die Chemie hat einfach gestimmt,
es musste so sein.
Dann haben wir uns dort oben -
es war ein wunderbarer Tag -
ein bisschen hingelegt.
Da gab ich ihr den ersten Kuss.
Sie war fast eingenickt nebenan,
da dachte ich:
"Diese Chance musst du packen!"
So hat sich das ergeben.
Jetzt bin ich eben
unheimlich glücklich mit Manuela.
Sie ist so eine Gute, und wir
haben es so schön miteinander.
Das ist mein Stolz.
Gell, Schatz?
- Ja, das ist unsere Geschichte.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Feierabend im Zoo von Magliaso.
Auch bei Sabina
ist es anders gekommen als erwartet.
Nicht wahr?
Gefällt dir das?
Du warst eben noch ein kleines Baby,
als wir das das letzte Mal machten.
Es war eigentlich
nichts zusammen geplant.
Also zuerst
war mal die Zooübernahme,
die hat jetzt länger gedauert
als erwartet.
Und ja, das Kind ist jetzt
einfach reingerasselt,
das hat jetzt einfach funktioniert.
* Quengeln *
Federico
wollte eigentlich keine Kinder,
heute kann er es sich
nicht mehr anders vorstellen.
* Quengeln *
Es ist 19.30 Uhr.
Cla Duri
wohnt mit seiner Familie im Dorf,
solange sein Vater
den Hof noch führt.
Er und seine Frau Nataglia
haben sich im Konfirmationsunterricht
kennengelernt, als sie 18 waren.
Wir haben halt früh Kinder bekommen,
24 war ich damals.
Und es hat sich herausgestellt,
dass es gut funktioniert.
Cla Duri hilft zu Hause viel mit.
Es gibt schon genug zu tun
mit dreien. Gerade jetzt.
Auf ihn muss man
die ganze Zeit aufpassen,
weil er keine Gefahr kennt.
Und du, du stellst auch
ab und zu etwas an.
Mias auch.
Wie es halt so ist.
Nataglia arbeitet
noch 30 % im Spital von Scuol.
Es ist doch noch etwas,
was man dazuverdient.
Aber im Moment ist es fast zu viel,
dass sie auch noch arbeitet.
Aber wenn sie jetzt für drei,
vier Jahre im Spital aufhören würde,
käme sie
nicht mehr in den Beruf zurück.
Das wäre eigentlich auch schade.
In Sulgen ist das Stroganoff fertig.
Teller wären noch gut.
Ich bringe sie,
ich bin näher als du.
Was die drei Frauen erlebt haben,
hat sie eng zusammengeschweisst.
Alle Themen und Probleme
werden am Familientisch diskutiert.
Auch, dass Rita im Moment single ist.
Viele meiner Freundinnen
sind schon ...
... verheiratet und haben Kinder.
Eine hat schon Kinder, bekommt
ihr drittes, ist jünger als ich.
Eine andere Freundin heiratet jetzt,
die anderen sind in einer Beziehung.
Es war so: Ich war
sechs Jahre lang in einer Beziehung,
da waren viele single.
Und jetzt ist es umgekehrt,
jetzt bin ich single.
Aber für mich
stimmt es im Moment so.
Einen Polizisten möchte sie.
(Lachend) Das sagen wir immer
so zum Spass, ein Polizist,
weil der die gleichen Arbeitszeiten
hat wie ich, er würde das kennen.
Oder ein Buschauffeur.
Ein Lieber.
Ein Lieber,
okay, damit kann ich leben.
In Appenzell
gibt es noch Abendprogramm.
Die Schwizers
musizieren regelmässig zusammen.
Irgendwann fragten die Kinder:
"Papa, du hast doch diese Örgeli,
können wir nicht
ein bisschen spielen?"
Dann übten sie fleissig damit.
Und dann packte es mich auch wieder.
Von da an
machten wir zusammen Musik.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Seine Kinder bedeuten ihm alles.
Ich hoffe,
sie können ihr Leben so gestalten,
dass sie auch mal
an einem schönen Ort sind -
egal, wohin es sie verschlägt.
Und vielleicht
auch eine Familie haben - ,
oder dass sie zufrieden sind
und einen Job haben,
der ihnen gefällt,
das ist schon wichtig.
Mir gefällt es, wenn sie üben.
Es ist noch schön,
wenn man Musik im Haus hat.
Die Kapelle Bienengift
hat sogar schon Preise gewonnen.
Es gibt nicht viele Appenzeller,
die einen Prix Walo im Zimmer haben.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Am Abend haben Sabina und Federico
den Zoo ganz für sich.
Während der Saison machen wir
diesen letzten Rundgang noch,
wenn alles zu ist,
wenn alle nach Hause gegangen sind.
Das ist ein bisschen,
um den Tag ausklingen zu lassen.
Es ist auch
ein wenig wie Ferien machen,
wenn alles schläft
oder schlafen geht
und wir in aller Ruhe
nochmals durch den Zoo gehen können.
Hast du es jetzt?
* Muhen *
Che fatica!
Ha finito?
Okay, sì. Ja.
So.
Es ist 20 Uhr.
Sabina ist um jede Minute froh,
in der sie Ruhe hat.
Buonanotte, dormi bene.
Darum ist es ihr
im Moment noch so recht,
gleich mit Lisa ins Bett zu gehen.
Spegniamo la luce?
No, quella la spegnie il papi.
Tu spegni quella grande qua.
Abend in der Schweiz.
(Rätoromanisch)
Cla Duri
ist ganz zufrieden mit seinem Leben.
So wie es jetzt ist, kann ich sagen,
dass ich eigentlich
alles richtig gemacht habe.
Vielleicht hätte man
die eine oder andere kleine Sache
anders machen können,
aber alles in allem würde ich sagen,
es ist gut so, wie es ist.
Gute Nacht, schlaft gut.
Oz haina strat aint, sai eu che ...
- Si, si.
Morgen stehen sie wieder auf.
Und mit ihnen mehr als 8 Mio.
andere Menschen in der Schweiz.
Jeder mit seinem Alltag
und mit seiner Geschichte.
Nächste Woche:
Canad Cali fährt mit dem Postauto
in die hintersten Täler des Tessins.
Denise Schöni betreut in der Region
Biel kranke Kinder zu Hause.
Roger Siegenthaler
ist Kranführer im Berner Oberland.
Maëlle Bertarionne
arbeitete in der Uhrenindustrie
und hat sich nach der Kündigung
selbstständig gemacht.